while president joe biden pretends that
his policies have not
created a crisis and a surge at the
southern border
the criminal coyotes who his
policies have empowered are saying
otherwise take a listen i'll translate
since i'm such an expert in spanish and
i can read subtitles
is business booming right now does it
pay well it does
even the situation with the people at
least that's what these two young men
say having built a highly profitable
business this is univision by helping
central american families seeking asylum
to cross into the us
we just come here to earn our daily
bread like everybody else says the
criminal coyote
in all honesty there are way too many
people with the benefits your president
is now granting
you know look man who am i i'm just a
small criminal coyote who abuses people
and breaks the laws of multiple nations
but man
your president is insane your president
is serious it's too much all right
please
we're getting too rich off of this say
the gangsters
aoc says that i am not supposed to call
what is going on at the border a surge
or a crisis i'm not allowed to do that
just because the numbers are surging
just because we obviously have a crisis
1500 capacity in some detention
facilities i'm not allowed to call it
either of those things because that
would make me
a racist they want to say what about the
surge
well first of all just
gut check stop anyone who's using the
term
surge around you consciously
is trying to invoke a militaristic frame
and that's a problem because
these this is not a surge these are
children and they are not insurgents
and we are not being invaded which by
the way
is a white supremacist
idea philosophy the idea that
if an other is coming in the population
that this is like an invasion of who we
are
invasion is a white supremacist
word so for instance when
uh like genghis khan's
armies were taking over and conquering
lands that was
that was white supremacy when the greeks
invaded troy that was white supremacy
were the trojans white or the greeks
white i'd uh
uh ed as just a technical matter
what is going on at the southern border
is an
invasion now the reason that one can
hesitate to call it an
invasion there are two reasons one the
the people who are coming in the foreign
nationals pouring across our border
illegally
are not armed and usually that the idea
of an invasion involves people being
armed preparing for armed conflict
and they're not which ties into the
second reason that one hesitates to call
it an invasion
namely they're being invited in by
democrats joe biden is actually saying
come
surge get over here get come on we want
you to come
he's using all those white supremacist
terms
but just as a as a purely technical
matter take all the emotion out of it
when a when a foreign people subject to
a
foreign state starts lawlessly pouring
across your border
in contravention of your of your
national borders of your sovereignty and
of your laws what do you call that
do you call that a dinner party no is it
closer to a dinner party or an invasion
i know it
seems to me very much the latter but but
she goes further than that
she says you can't call it a surge
they're not
it's not a surge it's children
yeah children can surge yes when we're
talking about the surge we're talking
about a rapid increase
in numbers and that is just what's
happening
it doesn't matter if it you can call it
a surge in bunny rabbits
at the local park it's not a surge it's
bunny rabbits right we're just talking
about the massive increase
in numbers that you're seeing because of
joe biden it's not a crisis
we're just oh right putting kids in
cages that same thing that aoc pretended
to cry about when trump did it
even though the policy wasn't even
originally a trump policy it's a policy
that dates back all the way
to the clinton administration so
so dishonest and what she does it works
obviously i fell for it
she she says things that are patently
absurd like
when people come in mass over a border
illegally you can't call that an
invasion or you're a white supremacist
and when numbers increase you can't call
it a surge and when
you're in a at a critical moment you
can't call it a crisis so she says
things that are just
incoherent indefensible and then she
gets all of us to be exasperated by it
but then
the terms of the discussion are on her
preferred battlefield right this is what
the left always does they get us to
argue
on their terms and so and we're doing it
right now i mean the reason i'm i'm
bringing this story up right now
is just to call your attention to this
rhetorical and political technique and
to call your attention to the central
strategy of political correctness which
i detail quite a lot in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
available now for pre-order which is
that they believe that if you redefine
the words
you can redefine reality if i say it's
not a crisis then you know what it's not
a crisis
if i say that a a whole lot of
foreigners
are not boring across our border i don't
even know what the argument she's making
is
then yeah then they're really not it's
not a surge it's not a surge
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you